we've talked about former president
trump's ridiculous lawsuit against a
bunch of big tech firms that
de-platformed him
and one of the arguments that he's
making is that these big tech firms were
deputized by the federal government to
effectively work as an arm of the
federal government now that is something
that
can happen if the federal government
contracts with a private company
then sometimes that private company can
be an arm of the government but these
are private companies that
haven't contracted with the federal
government and they haven't been
deputized by the government and
by the way the government that he's
talking about given the time frame
is the government that he was running at
the time which is particularly
ridiculous
but as many people have pointed out this
isn't so much a lawsuit that has any
chance of winning so much as a
fundraising effort by
trump and his campaign so look the
metrics for success are very different
so we're going to see trump in court for
a little while but not for very much
longer